I was at your party at Christmas
speaking with somebody about this very
subject I'm not making this up and going
by the way I am always in situations
where people start to go oh my god I
really love you and I love that thing
you did and it turns out to be you the
person that I was talking to it was
Martin Short really all the time people
I'm halfway through and I'm like whoa
whoa wait a minute you're talking about
Edie grimly not pee-wee Herman and
they're like oh I mean they know
people's a new difference people USU is
Martin Short
yes weight off this and does anyone ever
you think anyone ever goes up to Martin
Short and thinks that they're Paul
Rubens if they do Martin Short wasn't
kind enough to tell them that would have
been nice if he said that you could have
even made that up you know what I get a
little listening Marty I know your
friends got you Marty
god you're so much you're so filled with
venom I am a lot of good nerve hit a
nerve yeah a lot of people think I'm
Greta Gerwig I get that a lot now they
do
people say oh my god you're so young and
you're beautiful you're already taller
then yeah yours very tall and you do
little limb how did you direct Little
Women and I go and I'm happy in the
first part and then I suddenly I'm like
no no I'm not Greta Gerwig and then I
talked to Greta Gerwig and she said she
does not get mistaken for me I want to
meet Greta Gerwig I really could that's
a serious the real thing I'm saying it
on your show in case she's out there or
any of her friends are going go Greta
you know he could be sending you gifts
or gifs or whatever on your birthday
this a lot of celebrities listen to this
podcast really and I am I'm gonna say
and I'm not even kidding there's a 95%
chance that Greta Gerwig is listening
right now well I'm out to her people
already yo this is this is faster okay
so you're never gonna get through her
people okay you know after Little Women
that's a lot of people I loved Little
Women and I loved the other movie that
she made before that ladybird ladybird
really loved you I knew it did I have 90
bird that's the
Lyndon Johnson story it's the story of
Lyndon Johnson and the musical score was
by the weekend so it all comes together
all circle yeah I know a lot of cool
modern references you seem to be very
backwards backwards in it back in the
40s and the 50s but a day doesn't go by
that I'm not listening to the latest of
rap by awkwafina or you know you know
wearing the latest threads you even
think of another person - I said
Aquafina and I think that's enough don't
think I should be required
I know other names than that Paul you
and I I think don't need to know about
the modern world because we both live in
our own heads we're happy where we are
we don't need to know who all these
rappers are you know why do I need to
know what most def is doing